et pour en parler on va retrouver tout
de suite ashmat froz c'est un ami
d'enfance du commandant massoud
fondateur également de dahra une
association humanitaire pour l'éducation
en afghanistan
[Musique]
asmat france bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation dans la
matinale de rtl france il y a donc vingt
ans jour pour jour le commandant massoud
était assassiné c'était l'un de vos
proches racontez nous comment est ce que
vous l'avez connu
gelé connu parce quand les clients
semblent à partir de l'âge de 14 ans on
habitait dans le même quartier et on
allait à l'école ensemble ils avaient
trois ans de plus que moi mais également
dans le quartier il nous donnait des
cours de maths et la physique
ils adorent et enseigner et à partir de
ensuite en italie à la fac et comme je
suis allé à l'image quand je suis venu
en france massoud a été à l'université
polytechnique de kaboul et
malheureusement l'influencé russe était
très important en afghanistan il a pris
le chemin de la renaissance dans la
vallée du panchir ensuite deux côtés de
nouristan alors l'occident à qui voyait
dans le commandant massoud un allié
vingt ans plus tard les talibans annonce
la formation d'un nouveau gouvernement
quel est votre sentiment aujourd'hui sur
la situation de votre pays
le sentiment qu'on est lâchement
abandonnés par la communauté
internationale nous nous sommes battus
pendant 20 ans commandant massoud depuis
40 ans nous sommes battus et on arrive
au point zéro
massoud a été tuée au pôle pardonner
mais on peut pas pardonner que
aujourd'hui après vingt ans de
reconstruction de l'afghanistan
de nouveau l'histoire se répète de
nouveau entendre dans le cauchemar total
de nouveau les terroristes il n'obtient
les terroristes prennent le pouvoir je
ne comprends pas cette large lâcheté de
l'occident taux qui dans fui
l'afghanistan qu'ils ont donné la clé de
l'afghanistan au taliban et je pense que
les etats unis sans responsable de cette
défaite mais nous demandons nous
demandons tout simplement aux pays
voisins en particulier la russie qui
nous a soutenus pendant que les taliban
étaient au pouvoir il ya vingt ans en
afghanistan
il a soutenu le commandant massoud et en
demandent aux pays limitrophes en
particulier et l'air aussi de nous aider
pourquoi parce qu'aujourd'hui les
talibans alors au pouvoir à kaboul ils
vont pas se contenter de l'aide de miss
temps ils vont aller dans les pays
limitrophes dans la région est
particulière et des pays comme
l'ouzbékistan comme le cas jekyll temps
ils sont menacés donc le combat des zerg
ans et aujourd'hui le combat de tous les
hits centrale est le combat de tout le
monde effectivement effectivement il
fait aider la résistance
des toffees de massoud et aussi d'autres
combattants à l'intérieur de la
commission qui luttent tous les jours et
en particulier vous avez vu cette
soulèvement des femmes et des enfants
deux universitaires des étudiants à
kaboul et on a vraiment besoin d'un
soutien international au moins un
soutien de la région vous parliez du
fils du commandant massoud ahmad c'est
lui aujourd'hui un quart prix là la
résistance dans la vallée du panchir il
ya deux jours il a appelé à un
soulèvement national contre l'état bilum
liban est ce que vous vous avez des
informations de ce qui se passe sur
place
aujourd'hui les talibans ils ont pris la
kz2 là les deux prochaines la vallée du
panchir que ça représente environ 120 km
mais il ya plus de 60 40 pendant plus de
quarante balais à jassans dans laquelle
aujourd'hui les légendes de punch et
résistent ils prétendent occuper la
vallée mais à une existence très actifs
militaires existent il se bat tous les
jours entre eux et ça va continuer il ya
une forme de guérilla qui se forme
contre les taliban et et nous avons je
revienne là-dessus on prend et qui nous
avons besoin d'un soutien international
surtout des pays limitrophes c'est à
dire à son jardin pardonnez moi c'est à
dire un soutien militant r d armes par
exemple à à la résistance du ahmad
masood
exactement tout soutien matériel
ils font et financière et 2 est aussi
donata connaître le régime des talibans
et de le considérer comme et comme ils
sont les véritables terroristes
n'oublions pas le gouvernement qu'ils
ont mis à quelques jours en plate ce 17
d'entre eux dix-sept personnes d'entre
eux a été en prison à guantanamo
comment et sur la d sur la tête de tout
c'est plusieurs membres de ce
gouvernement des états unis avait mis
plusieurs millions d'euros et
aujourd'hui les mêmes qui arrivent au
pouvoir ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui les
terroristes ont gagné ça veut dire qu'il
faut laisser baisser les bras il faut
laisser faire et pourtant je répète
massoud a répété il ya vingt ans plus de
20 ans vous allez vous allez voir les
terroristes vont frapper quatre coins du
monde massoud n'a pas été entendu on a
vu les attentats de septembre 2001 on
avait d'autres attentats en france pas
bataclan ou comme un livre il y en a et
aujourd'hui si le fils ahmad masood bp
si on n'est pas écoutés il va avoir
d'autres attentats dans le cas de points
du monde justement il a appelé le le
fils ahmad masood le fils de du
commandant massoud a appelé à continuer
la résistance mais est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est pas perdre une avance
je pose qui tout un peuple grévistes on
peut pas accepter que 20 ans de 20 ans
d'efforts à la reconstruction
aujourd'hui que puisse se fondre comme
la neige au soleil oui mais tout seul on
peut pas se battre aujourd'hui pourquoi
la vallée du panchir à tomber parce
qu'il y avait des hélicoptères et des
avions qui sont venus directement du
pakistan pour bombarder le front uni à
dans la vallée aujourd'hui un soutien
très important logistique militaire du
pakistan et de qatari qui financent et
c'est la raison pour laquelle franchir à
tomber il talibans tout seul sans avoir
le quai du havre dernier au mercato d'al
quaida d'âge et d'autre il sauve pas
gagner aujourd'hui tous les peuples dans
l'ensemble délaissant est prêt à se
battre mais on a besoin d'une
reconnaissance on a besoin d'une autre
matériel militaire et financière et
aussi de reconnaissance diplomatique et
surtout de la pas connaître l'origine de
talibans et il va avoir un gouvernement
qui a été va être formé par ahmad masood
qui se sera gouvernement légitime de
l'afghanistan impose comme c'était le
cas à de gaulle en angleterre mais on
constate aussi beaucoup d'afghans de vos
concitoyens qui aujourd'hui ont fui ou
alors veulent fuir ou tentent de fuir
encore est ce que finalement c'est pas
un coup dur aussi pour la résistance
pour les quelques derniers résistants
qui pouvait rester dans le pays
bien sûr que c'est extrêmement difficile
bien sûr que les cerveaux sont partis
bien sûr que c'est dur pour la culture
abrial ce la raison pour laquelle on
vous dit et on répète tu es tout seul on
arrivera pas sans avoir le soutien de la
communauté internationale en particulier
en particulier de la russie et autres
pays alors aujourd'hui je vous propose
quelque chose de simple une base arrière
au tadjikistan que les nations unies que
l'heure est de pays comme le pakistan
comme comme le tadjikistan et comme le
jeu des questions de manière à recevoir
les réfugiés de l'intérieur et créer une
base dans ces pays là qui pisse de l'est
certains légimité qui encore une fois de
plus le pakistan ne reçoit pas l'aide de
la communauté internationale
comme quoi ils accueillent les réfugiés
aujourd'hui à plat le jargon qui sentent
leur vie qui est en danger il pourra
aller se réfugier aux pratiques aux
inspections et tadjikistan mais pour ça
il faut vraiment un soutien qu'elle met
ces pays peut-être cette dernière
question aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui reste
de l'esprit du commandant massoud en
afghanistan
l'expliquer pour nous c'est l'unique
espoir ça fait 40 ans que je suis avec
lui j'étais avec lui et aujourd'hui
c'est l'unique chemin d'aller vers la
liberté vers l'indépendance de
l'afghanistan pour que ce pays puisse
vivre et qu'ils puissent travailler avec
le monde entier c'est l'espoir
aujourd'hui l'héritage de commandes un
grand merci ashmat froz d'avoir répondu
à nos questions sur rt france ce matin
merci pour votre témoignage rappel vous
êtes un ami d'enfance du commandant
massoud mais également fondateur de
l'association d'art à associations